hey youtubers is Charlie so we got the
first trailer for the big flash Super
Girl crossover so let's break it down so
here's the deal if you're not cut up on
the flash just careful for spoilers for
what's happened on the flash so far and
there's not really anything spoilery for
Supergirl if you haven't been watching
that you might not really understand
what's going on between the members of
team Supergirl but you'll be able to
pick it up in a flash so prepare all of
your Supergirl flash puns
I can't wait it's gonna be so much fun
this is the official synopsis they
released and it's Supergirl episode 18
if you're counting Kara gains a new ally
when the lightning fast superhero the
flash suddenly appears from an alternate
universe and helps Cara battle Siobhan
aka silver Banshee in a livewire in
exchange for her help in finding a way
to return him home the title of the
episode is world's finest it's an Easter
Egg for the comics Superman in the flash
had a number of races in the comics one
of the biggest ones happened in world's
finest number 198 in 199 so if you
actually want to go back and read that
comic it might be fun but that's what
this promo image is all about if you've
been watching the flash this season you
know season 2 episode 2 the flash of two
worlds did the exact same thing with
this promo image the name of the comic
that the flash and Jay Garrick met for
the first time in is called the flash of
two worlds that was flash number 123 so
no coincidence that the people that make
the flash and also make Supergirl would
do the exact same thing with this comic
book cover it's a lot of fun usually
they save stuff like this for the really
special episodes and this is a huge deal
because Supergirl is happening on CBS
and even though Time Warner owns a
little bit of both CBS and CW
traditionally it would be logistically
impossible to get a show in Vancouver on
a different network to crossover with a
show that shoots in Los Angeles now the
flash and arrow are produced at the same
network that's why crossovers are so
much easier so that is why this very
first crossover is them just kind of
dipping their toe in the water just
having Grant Gustin come on Supergirl
they said if it's successful they will
totally do it again next year and you'll
probably see Supergirl go on the flash
and actually in related news Stephen
Amell actually said something really
cool at heroes and villains fan fest he
always gets asked about crossovers and
he said that he was having dinner with
the president of the CW network one
night and he was like hey are we ever
gonna do a three night crossover because
most of their crossovers are just one
crossing over with another like he went
on legends of tomorrow as old Oliver
Queen the flash and arrow cross over but
what about a three-night crossover with
the flash arrow and legends of tomorrow
and he said the president of the CW
network said something that he couldn't
repeat which basically means he dropped
an f-bomb
but then followed it with yes of course
we're gonna do a three-night crossover
so next season because all those shows
got renewed just expect a giant three
night crossover on the CW
when Supergirl crosses over with the
flash like when she comes on the flash
it'll probably be relatively
self-contained because I don't know if
they would do a four night crossover
that would be crazy maybe in like three
years when arrows in season seven where
it really is like TV Justice League you
have Supergirl flash arrow in any other
big heroes that they have on the show at
the time together flash and Supergirl
though how the hell does Barry get to
Cara's earth if all the portals have
been closed because just talking about
the flash storyline this season they
have to defeat zoom in order to do that
they have to get back to earth-2 they
can't defeat them if they can't
physically get to him so let's look at
some of the dates here we can actually
guess what might end up happening the
next episode of the flash is March 22nd
that crossover with Supergirl is the
next week that next Monday March 28th so
what they might do in the next episode
of the flash is have a post-credits
scene where Barry accidentally jumps to
Cara's earth and you get this WTF and
then they just pick it up on Supergirl
Barry has a long history of not totally
understanding how his powers work
derping traveling back in time on
accident that's probably what ends up
happening when he ends up on cara's
earth whatever solution they used to
weave the story between one show and
another it's gonna be pretty simple
pretty easy to follow the only other
funny thing I've heard about the
crossover is he's just gonna have some
chemistry with Supergirl and they're
just gonna have some fun with that so
just expect Cisco on the following
episode of the flash after the crossover
to be asking Barry about this really hot
girl who called herself a Kryptonian did
you get her phone number
but just remember because Supergirl is
on another network now they are
connected via the multiverse they're
still gonna be relatively self-contained
to each network so you're not gonna see
Supergirl talking about the flash all
the time if you guys didn't know the
character that plays silver Banshee on
Supergirl is actually the real-life wife
of Robbie Amell the original firestorm
so nice Easter Egg for that and
should actually say the way they did the
title world's finest is also kind of an
easter egg in and of itself this is
really something for grammar nazis so in
the comics it was worlds with apostrophe
here as in the single world's finest the
TV show because it's doing this with the
multiverse is worlds no apostrophe as in
the finest from multiple worlds so
comic-book e straight for all you
grammar nazis out there but let me know
in the comments what kind of crossover
do you want to see them do when
Supergirl eventually comes on to the
flash TV show like what would she be
doing in Central City to help Barry and
I know some of you have asked about it
but I'm totally gonna be doing a
Supergirl video I don't usually do
Supergirl videos every week but I'm
totally gonna do a Supergirl video with
all the Easter eggs and stuff so don't
worry about that and just to remind you
flash and arrow are coming back next
week this Friday daredevil is dropping
I'll be posting videos at least every
couple days I'll try to get through all
the episodes in a single week it might
not be quite that fast but be sure to
subscribe to get everything and then
Batman V Superman is also dropping next
week so there's a lot of crazy Marvel
and DC stuff happening in the next two
weeks I'm working on a new spider-man
video next but why do you guys wait for
that you can click here for my last big
daredevil trailer and you can click here
for my flash season 3 video thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight